okay so we'll play the game again where
uh he's trying to touch my chest
okay
are we going
so
all right so you said he kept getting
your chest all right let's see some go
okay so some of these passes that you're
doing these these tessa bucky passes
you're doing they're they're okay
but you don't have uh
any of your ikea or your coq
taking his balance
so eventually he's going to get it
because he's offense he has the
initiative you're reactionary
at how you're doing it okay
so you for example uh he he pushed okay
and i saw you come around very nice okay
so
he pushed he didn't block him
you push you yielded and he came to this
one but then nothing happened to his
balance and there it is
so same thing he comes around you yield
but there
so if we watch again there's two things
that are doing this hand is already
taken off balance so i could take this
one over
but usually i go here this hands is dead
that's how he got in
so if he comes around i yield here this
hand was not dead even though this he's
pushing here this hand is still doing
something boom there it is right
or you could he pushes you pass and it
goes right into there there's your
there's your concu
so you pass this
and of course you can do the two
together
but you can't just that your your
you have a coke you you have a
separating force right so well we're
here well a separating force and you
have an adhesion force you understand so
coccus separating force
adhesion force but both of them
are working towards a kazushi
so i either bring him into the front
corner
or the back corner on either side back
corner front corner or you can of course
always go
right through but
you don't just
stay out in his hands
okay he's gonna get you eventually
so as he passes
as you go you always take his balance
there he's in the front corner he comes
back and i push
[Music]
boom i key project
i think project
boom pop
he goes whatever boom
so we'll do that one again
right here like this he goes around
right take the elbows
with a coccu projection
he's going to do something bob there he
goes in
right he's coming in parry
boom around we'll do it again
so here is the eye key on this hand ikea
on this end caulk you on that hand to
keep that corner out okay
then i'll bring it around
pass through the ikey phase and now it's
back in the coq phase on this hand and
this hand over here is the ikey phase
okay so you can see that you're going uh
is that what we did i don't know what
you did
okay all right
uh yeah it was almost on the outside so
this hand has a coq at first
this hand will have an eye here at first
so this sound here it has an adhesion
going
oh it's not blocking him
this hand is blocking him
but as this hand
passes through the ikey face
it's now going to be in the cold cue
phase and you can see over here is the
adhesion
but both of them are working together to
take his balance
okay so you can't just be here
not take balance
you can only stick and follow for so
long it's gonna get you okay and it's
also not the drill
all right
let's try again
all right all right so you you're
talking about this world of power once
you feel like you can't get it you enter
into a contest stating mindset you
against her
okay so
what what ends up happening as i said is
now you're in dichotomy
but it's a dichotomy that's working
through the through fear and through a
will to power
and what ends up happening is you you
start this path of annihilating the
other okay so in this case is where
instead of one hand being yin one hand
being young or in other words one hand
being ikey in one hand in communion and
the other hand in separating force call
q
you have like two just pushing hands
okay so go
right there it was
two pushing hands
pushing your thumb do you see your thumb
hooked her
you're just trying to stop her from
going
okay
okay and as you fluctuate in this
dichotomy and a lot of you're doing this
you you start to go on off
in the way that you're touching her
center like you're you're
sometimes you are then you go off
because you want to save yourself
and then you go back on and so and
because you go off that's what triggers
the fear response because now comes at
you and on rush or quickly or something
you feel behind you feel overpowered you
feel they're going to get you okay
okay
so first thing to mention is uh
uh
then this is probably for the more
advanced okay
so yin yang is
a theory in relativity
so
that means
while it is true
it's only true from a point of view
which means it's false from another
point of view okay
so uh the way i described it
um
earlier it's very convenient and it's
very easy for someone to understand
because it's presented in a binary kind
of fashion but it's ultimately not true
okay because it's relative
um
i let's say you're not you're not
pushing on this hand there's no there's
no energy on this hand okay that that's
not true that's not a true statement
the energy on this hand whether there is
some or is not some is only relative to
in this case the energy of my hand
you see so if i'm trying to shove this
hand that feels like no energy in this
thing but if i match if i match that i'm
matching it i'm matching it matching it
matching
so
in other words
this will not project you if you relax
your hand you relax your super super yin
you super yin that will not project you
but if i go more yin than you
you see then this hand is now
young so you're going more yen i go more
yin you go more yin i go maury is you
trying to relax i i relax more you see
and then
you see all right it's still clearly on
him
do you understand that okay so
this is the downside of flexing and
pushing because you're going to make
their
energy yin by comparison okay and now
they're always yielding to what you're
doing and so they're always in essence
countering to what you're doing
that's how they like get so slippery on
you okay so
uh when i feel like for example you try
to go around my hand you see i stay
lighter and now now it's stuck again i
just stay light like like like
whereas uh you try to go around my hand
and look it came off of my hand okay
so you go around my hand to touch my
chest right boom are you gonna touch my
chest
there you're gonna touch my chest touch
my chest here's my chest okay there you
go
i go light right now
i just go light
light
and it's stuck
this is important because you can't
i think what you're doing is you're
trying to play the other game
but you unders the game i i explained
over there without realizing
it's partly not true
okay because it's a theory in relativity
okay
so
uh and that's important because what
when i feel it go off like i don't have
your center you see it goes off i can
keep your center by being light
you see you get it and so it never went
off
although i just went more yin than you
which made you young okay
as opposed to i'm off and i'm always
trying to catch you up and try to stop
you with thumb hooks and groups and
things like that
okay so you're gonna feel that i i i'm
always in your center you're trying to
touch my chest i'm always in your center
even even here always in the center look
he's in five steps
[Music]
so when i'm going for more event no no
for more advanced people
what i am trying to do
is
really see
how
much i can change any hidden energy
you're doing to young energy
okay you got it right and so to do that
i can't be in those contests so again
i'm really light here but you can't push
forward
never be off in your center
in the moment
and sometimes you're like oh
i can't get
this okay don't get it
but even as you push you push down on
your right
can you come in no you can't so i can
still
that way but i didn't use it do you see
i just kept it there so i i went ahead
and adhered on this side you see
if you start
pulling that back and softness and
you'll see me go soft do you see and
then sand i owe you
i reached for your beginning remember i
said you came up
uh if you didn't put your hand you see
how i'm still using it okay if you put
your hand i reach for you if you pull
your hand into you hey in into you like
you did that last friend when you come
up i see connection right away you see
that so i don't want to in the same
spirit of don't go on and off
don't start over
come up and now we start over
no okay so once we start the game
[Music]
right you went up to his shoulder and uh
and do whatever
do whatever
so you went around this hand
you see
went around this town one more time you
did
there you go and then but who cares
hello i've got you you're
protecting your engagement so it brought
you in and you came up with my arms here
right
so i brought you in you came up and
that's where the
projected energy
okay
so if again
maybe i can't hit you tristan pretend
you maybe i cannot
because you're just out here going like
this
you see so he's out there bowling but
look i pulled
he's what's he going to do he's going to
try to go back out
okay
there you can use that on that id
adhesion part so i'm correcting lots of
people here so here it is again he's
he's so balanced but look if i just take
it a little bit
and before he loses all his balance and
try something else right you can do
something else and that's when you have
a perfection
okay
all right lots to work on three
different people got corrections